And to finish up I'd like to have just have a quick look at something called Material
Parameter Collections. Now we can see here we are on slide 21 and highlighted should be
something that's called a Material Parameter Collection. Now this can be created by coming
under material and you'll see that it's the third one down here, Material Parameter Collections.
And these are very simple. What they are is just a set of variables but they are a global
universal source. These variables that can then be referenced in numerous different places. So if
you have a look at what we've got here, I'm just going to fire this up, we have two. We have a
scalar parameter and a vector parameter in this. So one scalar parameter meaning it's a singular float
and we're calling this speed. So this is set to 3.85 and a vector parameter that we're using
to define a color. Now if I was to look at this level you can see that we've got a number
of elements here. If I change the color you can see that all of these different materials
change the color at the same time. And beyond that if I slow down the speed say to one
you can see that the throbbing of the pipes and the bubbling of the water and the moving
of the machinery all slows down as well. I change it down to zero you can see that everything
stops and even the glowing stops on this kind of generator material that I've used.
And if I change this up to let's say 30 you can see that it speeds up to an incredibly fast
speed, 10 probably do. And there are little, let's take it to six, that's more reasonable.
You can see the little thunderbolts going between. So the point we're trying to get to here is
this can be used and if I was to jump into this material this will show us how we can use this.
It's a very simple material but we're using a parameter collection. So at this point if I was
to come in and type collect you can see that there is a collection parameter and in this
it's going to allow us to select the different parameters. In this case we're just using example
and with the drop down you can see we have color and speed. So I was to select speed and place
that into I don't know roughness for example. Now we would see on this cube here as I updated
the speed to zero you see that this is now incredibly smooth. So these are universal values
and we can use them and update them and they can be referenced in lots and lots of different
places. For example you might have a value for how wet a place was and that could be used to
control different sort of dripping of water and how large puddles were. So you could use them
in numerous different ways. Also this is specular. Okay now I want to do one final
exercise to sort of demonstrate how you might programmatically control a material parameter
collection and for that if you were to press play you would see that we had a couple of
buttons here and a slider in our sort of heads up display and none of these are connected up so
let's do that now. So if I get rid of that what I'm going to do is I am going to double
click on w underscore mpc exercise and we open this up and see that we're going to have something
that looks a little bit like this. Now these are the buttons so what we're going to do is
this is a slider and the buttons we're going to connect these ones up. So if I jump into
the graph you can see here we have on the value change power slider and we have a red blue green
button and a yellow button here. So I'm going to drag off of the power slider one
and I'm going to search for set scalar parameter value and we can see that this is under a
material and the rendering and we we've already got the option to select a collection. So again
we're using example so I'll search for example and after I've filled out the collection
at the drop down I can select speed because that's the only that's the only scalar parameter.
Now the value itself only goes from zero to one so I'm going to multiply this
so I'm going to multiply it by six to give us our parameter value. So that should work for the
power slider. The next thing we need to do is connect up the buttons. So to do that what
we're going to need is drag off of here and go set a vector parameter value. You can see here
under materials set vector parameter value and again we're going to select the example
material parameter collection and we've only got color because we we're setting a vector. Now in
order to set the color I'm going to drag off of the blue pin and type in make color and this
will allow me to to type in the color. So our first one is red so I'm going to put one in red
then I'm going to copy all of this and I'm going to paste it each one of the other buttons the
second one is blue so I'll get rid of the one from mine and I'll put one into blue.
Next one is green so I'm going to put one in green and zero in red and the final one is
yellow which I think requires a one in green and a one in red. Okay so that should be all the
code we need. We have those are the two nodes compile and save. Now if I jump back to the level
and push play you can now see that we can change the values by updating the
updating the power slider and we can change the colors by clicking on the clicking on these
buttons. Now one of the things you might notice is we also have a dial here which is completely
built in materials and that is connected to the power dial there so we can see how we can
also access or show you that quickly so I escape out and go to look back at the material
you can see that we have a dial here and we've not needed any coding for this at all
because this too is using it's a bit slightly more complicated but it's using the speed parameter
collection in order to change the value that we've got coming in here so you can see if I'd
manually put this in it would change according to the value placed into it.
So again we're just using using one parameter speed and then we are using it in numerous
different materials in order in different ways in order to create different effects
and that is in one centralized place which you can easily update via coding so you can see
it's just a very very simple straightforward way of updating it and with that that brings us
to the end of interactive materials. I hope that's been useful to you and do feel free
to pick through all of the examples that are in in this file or go back to it and thank you very
much.